hello so the last time we saw spock he
was reeling from the loss of his sister
so where is he mentally when we reunite
with him in strange new worlds i think
that spock at the beginning of strange
new worlds is in a very
sort of fragile place he's just had this
huge trauma in his life
um this sort of unraveling that's
occurred with his contact
with the red angel with the loss of his
sister to
time
um and really nobody that he's allowed
to speak with it about
um i suppose there are select few that
are around him but there's so much he
has to attend to day to day i don't
think that he can dedicate much of his
energy to consideration of of that part
of his life
um so i think he's uncertain
i think he's seeking
uh of himself and of
uh the right perspective in the universe
he's he's betwixt these two two worlds
right he's from born and raised on
vulcan but is also half human
and these are in such conflict with each
other which is what i hope and think
makes him such a compelling character um
so he's in this place of experimentation
excellent and then in the trailers we
get to see his relationship with spring
uh what is it like playing a character
in a romantic fashion who's such a
reserved character
it's really wild and it's frightening
because there's not much of a blue
blueprint for it
so for instance with that scene we all
you know in front of him behind the
camera approach that scene with such
caution and trepidation um and with
respect to what's been done and
into what we interpret to be is the
right thing and there was a lot of
discussion
and so
uh on that level it was like
this really
difficult and complex problem to solve
and also kind of thrilling to be to be
playing that background
excellent and then we get to meet ahora
and this strange new world so what was
it like getting to play out that first
introduction between these two
characters
and well now in retrospect absolutely
wonderful
in the moment i really try not to think
too much about how things will be
perceived
so i do as much to be in the center and
in the perspective of this character
who's just having it having an
experience
um so
for me it's quite different than
probably how it appears to be from the
outside of which even now i'm not sure i
have that perspective yet um
maybe in some years i'll better be able
to answer that question excellent oh
what episode are you most excited for
fans to see
oh
oh that's a great question
personally i really enjoyed
making episode seven and i think that's
all i can say about that
good to know uh and then for a fun
question if you could switch roles with
any other character in strange new
worlds who would it be and why
oh
really interesting question
i spent so much time with christina
chong and her
sort of development of her character la
on and that character has such a rich
emotional history that maybe i would
switch places with her
um because it just seemed like
so fun and so challenging to sort of
uncover and explore that character
that's an excellent answer and that is
such a great character i mean so many of
these characters are fascinating she's
got a rich history yeah
excellent well that was all the
questions i had for you and it looks
like we are at the end
all right cool thanks so much
you